[Musik]
bis die aussagen euro
[Gelächter]
so wurden herz richard kelly war der
erste offizielle fahrt der schweiz
das heißt er sucht für ein schweizer
warenhaus auf der ganzen welt
kulinarische spezialitäten
ich begleite ihn quer durch portugal
für mich klingt das nach einem traumjob
da ich mir fast pausenlose meister ist
pausenlos unterwegs das muss wegen nicht
viel im auto blieb nicht viel zeit zum
morgen also kostüme mögliche ausmaß dem
trink und doch immer konzentriert sie
das
das hat man in portugal hat er vier tage
zeit um neuer delikatessen zu finden
wie er das macht und welche preise dafür
zahlt davon handelt dieser film die
reise beginnt in porto im nordwesten des
landes in einer sardine fabriken
[Musik]
ich habe einen termin mit beton
hallo
ein bein
[Musik]
bis 6
zeugniskopien
überhaupt kann irgend ein traum betriebs
noch sehr gut und die sind jetzt
nachholen
ich nehme noch eine sardinen makrelen
und thunfisch in büchsen nicht gerade
das was ich mir unter exklusiven
delikatessen vorstellen die
portugiesische küche gilt als arme leute
küche
die leute brauche ich aber genau darum
so hinter sich und schlug auf wilders
wird globo überhaupt schwimm club wo wir
irgendwelche bewerten und das ich bin
ich bilde spannenden buch die aus tokio
wo unsere möbel bloß diesen luxus
geworden trotzdem luxus ist katys alltag
sein arbeitgeber die globus delikatesse
bewegt sich im oberen preissegment
richard kelly ist verantwortlich dafür
die passenden spezialitäten für
promotionen zu finden
je exotischer und exklusiver umso besser
viel mehr als nur der hohe maßstäbe
leistung das richtige lifestyle wurde
und es heißt ja auch dass man sich jetzt
ein gros bmw vollständig hochrisiko
großeinkauf heute abend bewertet der
hobbykoch 20 gäste ursprünglich ist
richard kelly maschinenmechaniker und
hat später erfolgreich in der
gastronomie gearbeitet den globus kopie
h4 kann ich mir dann so quasi stelle
beschrieben die nächsten 21 geworden
zurück nach porto dem start der reise
durch portugal ein bisschen
maschinenmechaniker ist cable immer noch
er baut motorräder um ganz nach wunsch
seiner internationalen kundschaft auch
kelly hat ihn vor ein paar monaten eine
maschine anvertraut jetzt will er wissen
wie weit der umbau ist
lasst uns umschauen schlechtes zeichen
sein töff steht im keller zwischen
dutzenden von anderen die auf ihren
umbau warten und meine ist das ist die
650 yamaha wo ein bisschen anders
ausgesehen aber das lange sitzen neben
den kann man nicht so viel machen will
der vater staat die wand ist egal ob
portugal dann wird sie ziemlich
angefressen
der 63 jährige liebäugelt mit einer
ferienwohnung in portugal
im moment ist er aber auf einer anderen
mission
wir fahren 100 kilometer gegen osten in
die douro region ein weingebiet
[Musik]
im luxushotel six senses hat er gegen
abend einen termin
sein job bringt ihnen in die edelsten
häuser auf der ganzen welt dieses
unstete leben aber hat seinen preis
natürlich es war mir wichtig sind und
die zimmer seien völlig die shows ein
oder andere bruch gegangen wie ich halt
viel unterwegs bin
aber es ist mir halt doch sehr wichtig
er ist geschieden und hat zwei
erwachsene kinder lebt aber wieder in
einer beziehung
unterwegs ist er meist alleine er sei
ein einzelgänger
für die promotion braucht er einen
spitzenkoch der in der schweiz typische
gerichte zubereitet der koch dieses
hotels könnte passen
kg trifft sich mit den
marketingverantwortlichen und versucht
ihnen den plan schmackhaft zu machen
sie kommen von einer zeitschrift waren
aus in basel das schweizer warenhaus
kennt den portugal niemand obwohl es
inzwischen fast zehn uhr abends ist
bekommt er noch ein probe menü serviert
das was man sie da haben das ist perfekt
handwerk und website produkte und grafik
und
das ist ziemlich kuriose bilder macht
und ich sehe was der sommer doch es ist
zu spät
der koch hat schon feierabend fazit des
ersten tages fischkonserven der tüv
immer noch in der garage und ein
durchschnittlicher spitzenkoch
[Musik]
am nächsten besuch bei einem olivenöl
produzenten jungbauer daniel martins
führt richard kelly stolz seinen
olivenhaine vor
er produziert rein biologisch auf neun
hektar an land diese bäume sind ungefähr
40 jahre alt sie sind nicht sehr groß 40
jahre ich dachte die seine 56 jahre alt
es hat sehr viel frucht und das ist
schon mal der nase und der rechte doch
dann merkt man im gange viel luft dazu
jetzt ist das richtig aktiviert wird die
mut und da merkt mit bitterkeit sofort
die mund- und dann aber schlucken
erschienener schärfe und druckt einmal
und fruchtigkeit und schärfe das sind
die drei positive kriterien von olivenöl
diese art olivenöl schmeckt den meisten
leuten
ich persönlich mag lieber die stärkere
richard kelly ist perfektionist nicht
nur der geschmack auch das äußere muss
stimmen der olivenbauer wird spürbar
nervös ich werde ihm die halbe
jahresproduktion abkaufen
das ist sehr wichtig richard ist mein
fester ins ausland und natürlich wenn
man so einen ort ergab nicht moderner
gelassen und dann wird man zum teil
harmonie gerade aber da ist es gehe und
dass eine und da das passiert also
kleiner flamme und dann ist das okay und
wirklich der olivenbauer latin food
scout aus der schweiz zum essen ein
es gibt traditionelle gerichte in dieser
region vor allem deftige würste
kra frieda wieder andere wurscht und
andere kreis und weil man da erzählt hat
360 gewünscht haben welche produkte ins
sortiment aufgenommen werden entscheidet
aber der einkäufer in der schweiz
meistens seien sie sich einig nach dem
mittagessen nimmt daniel martins den
food scout mit zu seinem freund marco
der pc sammelt
sehr schön so begeistert habe ich den
fuß kaut auf der ganzen reise noch nicht
erlebt die getrockneten pilze verkauft
marco in erster linie an restaurants
dann entdeckt richard kelly noch ein
anderes produkt gemahlenes pulver das
ist
und ich erinnere mich mit der form zum
bruch wenn das hobby zum beispiel ins
rote meer streuen bild zu hause zum ubs
risotto jetzt geben wir das sind nur ein
paar wenige meiner produkte im dorf hat
es sich herumgesprochen dass ein fuß
kaut da ist das ist eine wurst aus
fleisch und kirchen es heute bisher
hörte einfach dass der zwei polizei
wurden und das braucht das sind zu große
baustelle und zehn ideal zum aufträge zu
erfüllen um ihre produktionsmethoden
stellen
diese produkte sind für mich zu speziell
und sie sehen nicht wirklich appetitlich
aus das auge ist eben mit erfolgreicher
zweiter tag der portugal tour olivenöl
würste und als krönung das pulver
am nächsten morgen unterwegs zu einer
käserei kelly hat auf der ganzen welt
informanten die ihn bei bedarf ihre
tipps weitergeben
den termin in der käserei hat er noch
von der schweiz aus vereinbart
[Musik]
stolz wird ihm der besitzer seine
produktepalette vor
ich interessiere mich für solche käse
[Musik]
das ist ziegenkäse ich hätte ihn schon
etwas früher öffnen sollen damit er
atmen kann und einen geist gemacht also
für und dann leute bei mir die
alarmglocken
[Musik]
wahrscheinlich wären der besitzer will
ihm unbedingt noch die kürzlich
erweiterte produktion zeigen ich merke
wie sich die laune von richard kelly mit
jedem satz des käserei chefs
verschlechtert natürlich vorstoß gab
letzte woche einen container nach
brasilien geschickt hat er hat das ganze
aber weiter in den süden in richtung
allen die show auf der dreistündigen
fahrt haben wir zeit um über seine
leidenschaft fürs essen und die
schattenseiten seines jobs zu sprechen
wedel
ich bin in der regel sehr kritischem an
und
ich merke dass einmal wieder wir
praktisch nehmen solange über nicht
geladen wo bekomme ich mache es aber
viele legen aber das passiert fragte
stellt
oder befreundete wirkten kommentare und
die sind minister mann oder freund wie
zuletzt
abends kommen wir im hotel barocken
morgen ist der letzte tag der reise
was immer noch fehlt ist ein spitzenkoch
für die portugal wochen nach dem
frühstück fädelt der fußhaut einen
besuch in der küche ein
ich würde gerne mit den köchen sprechen
hallo ich bin richard wissen sie wieso
ich hier bin ich glaube schon
sie wollen meine küche sehen ja ich
würde mich gerne etwas umsehen
wie würden sie ihr rad zu kochen
beschreiben
meine art zu kochen
einfache geschmäcker lokale und
regionale zutaten ganz einfaches essen
aber mit technik einfach sehr sorgfältig
zubereitet ja mit viel liebe und
sorgfalt
richard kelly blüht in dieser küche
geradezu auf ob es an der hübschen
jungen köchin oder den leckeren
gerichten liegt ist schwierig zu sagen
[Musik]
was sie macht das ist kein haus und ich
sagte typisch portugiesischen hoch wie
sehr sorgt weil die produkte aus der
region
traditionelle krieg mit dem thema
moderne tanz und wieder hoch kirche
mariä geburts karma da drin und da wird
beim burgrock um ganz sicher zu gehen
lässt sich ein paar der spezialitäten
servieren
das sind die farben ohne
unvorhergesehene fälle zusammen mit der
so stück wurst vom schwarzen schwan
das schwarze schwein das möchte der
katzenliebhaber zum abschluss der
portugall tour noch sehen
der hotelmanager hat ihm erzählt dass
die tiere ganz in der nähe in einem
nationalpark leben
aus ihnen wird der berühmte pata negra
schinken hergestellt und den wiki
unbedingt in der portugal promotion
haben
[Musik]
ja und
ein schweine bein hat er aus portugal
mit nach hause genommen
[Musik]
heute abend bewertet er bei sich privat
in zürich 20 zahlen der gäste und
serviert den schinken zum absender
einige morde pro jahr veranstaltete er
solche abendessen in seinem eigenen
wohnzimmer
ein befreundeter koch und kelly schon
helfen nicht
obwohl katie nicht koch ist traut er
sich zu zahlende gäste zu bewirten
es macht ist die frage was macht ist ich
habe natürlich dürfen poor s tronic city
und physiotherapie mit den dünen und
irgendwelcher übernehmen ist oder pasten
gusto und will dass ich eine spannend
war man bisher beim erwachen hat man
auch immer probieren heute serviert er
einen sieben gänge in so einem abend
stecken zwei tage arbeit ich frage mich
wieso hat das macht denn nötig hätte er
es nicht
ich nehme mich hat katie seine
leidenschaft für das gute essen an
für ihn ist es nicht beruf sondern
berufung
[Musik]